you know American comics came out with
the tradition of the Sunday newspaper
supplement so they were very strong on
graphics and Karla we're as British
comics have grown out of text magazines
with it added illustrations and we kind
of mixed the two of them together and we
always wanted to do comics myself Brian
Bolland Alan Moore Kevin O'Neill Nick
McMahon everybody who ended up in the
2000ad clubhouse we were the lunatics
who took over the asylum I remember the
first time I came to New York I did I
wasn't interested in the Empire State
Building or Statue of Liberty what I
wanted to see were the fire hydrants in
the street that Jack Kirby used to draw
or the water towers on the top of the
downtown buildings there's Steve Ditko
used to draw in his spider-man comics
and I think that was vital to the way
that we did Watchmen
we could stand back from the conventions
of American comics and see them slightly
differently I vividly remember a comic
convention in London in 1980 and they
had people dressed up as the Marvel
characters at the Hulk had a big muscle
suit and he kept fainting because it was
so hot and Wolverine was kind of a
somatic he could breathe in his costume
you know in spider-man he's having
trouble with his jockstrap and you know
couldn't quite get comfy and I you know
and that was perhaps prophetic because
you know what Alan and I later did with
Watchmen was to imagine how he would
really be to wear these costumes when I
was growing up I was a mod okay I had a
scooter and all that kind of thing and I
was interested in black dance music and
everything
Alan is clearly of the hippie persuasion
they're really tall guy with long hair
and a beard and a suit that was a couple
of sizes too small and a big plastic bag
full of comics and I got some of his
stories to draw and I immediately could
see that he really
was a singular talent you know when you
draw comic but it's the worst thing in
the world is to have to spend months
drawing something that somebody is just
written very quickly and just fluffed
off Allen never does that so he spurred
his work would spur me on to put even
more at the entry
it's easy to forget what it was like in
the ages there was a very real threat of
nuclear war Allen had this this this
vivid experience one day where he saw
some police forces like the gas masks on
they were ready for a riot and they were
going to use tear gas and there was a
sense about unreality about it and also
a sense of what can we do what can you
possibly do and I mean Watchmen in a way
is about that
how can you resolve these fastening
possible things one of the characters
says nothing ever ends you might
resolved it for now but nothing ever
ends it wasn't just another comic book
it was something singular and special
and different